dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if I hear a caustic
is a beautiful phenomenon in nature
we're curved surfaces reflect or refract
light thereby concentrating it to a
relatively small area if it's not your
favorite visual phenomenon in nature yet
which is almost impossible then you
absolutely have to watch this episode if
it is all the better because you're
gonna love what's coming up now imagine
that we have a photorealistic rendering
program that simulates the path of light
rays in a scene that we put together and
creates beautiful imagery of our
caustics however since we humans are
pretty bad at estimating how exactly
caustics should look like one can
manipulate them to be more in line with
their artistic vision previously we had
an episode on a technique which made it
possible to pull the caustic patterns to
be more visible but this paper offers a
much more sophisticated toolset to
torment these caustic patterns to our
liking we can specify a target pattern
that we would like to see and obtain a
blend between what would normally happen
in physics and what we imagined to
appear there it also supports animated
sequences artists who use these tools
are just as skilled in their trade as
the scientists who created this
algorithm so I can only imagine the
miracles they will create with such a
technique if you are interested in
diving into photorealistic rendering
material modeling and all that cool
stuff there are completely free and
open-source tools out there like blender
that you can use if you would like to
get started check out scenic add pros
YouTube channel that has tons of really
great material
here's a quick teaser of his channel
thanks gallery over on Seneca Pro I do a
bunch of art related videos and I also a
while back did a physically vacating
series talking about how light interacts
with materials and how we can model that
in blender cycles which is a render that
Kaduri is used on a couple occasions to
show off a rate tracing it's actually a
really fun program and worth checking
out if 3d art or anything in that
vicinity is your jam maybe come check me
out and yeah thanks for the time cutaway
and back to you
Thanks there is a link to his channel in
the description box make sure to check
it out and subscribe if you like what
you see there I just realized that the
year has barely started and it is
already lavishing in beautiful papers
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time